welcome to this video let's see
playing pop wall 29 from from Poland
yeah I got it right for once
okay let's see you have the news oh and
I choose Quincey - okay I've tried some
some other line 96's the repertoire
choice in my upcoming book but this line
here is also interesting it leads to a
hedgehog type of position black will
play Bishop d7 yeah there should be 7d
697 and set up the typical Hedgehog Oh
ha he castles long which is very
uncommon against a natural formation
okay let's see
okay whatever I just take see phones
their massive trick coming up I don't
see it
let's see for us somehow important pawn
controlling the center
you know I need to drop all the way back
yeah this is some attacking d6l probably
should just just push it and the knight
doesn't have a great square to go to
yeah Bishop f6 isn't a good idea sir I
need to take with the night and now we
can at least go to e5 which looks like
an active move but 94 is a good idea now
before before as an additional option
yeah I haven't I haven't cancelled yet
so um miss Advantium it's not them
fastening so much yeah d4 I guess but
I'm not attacking the knight g5 is also
hanging yeah so I thought I should play
that
but what now
maybe you win ce7 now quincy 7 was a
good idea and i unlock on one before I
can take that 4 yeah this looks looks
good okay he just retreated I intended
to go here
I can play Roxy one mmm
I forgot about that but he didn't didn't
really use this option
still see one can still play Roxy one
hmm okay
I still I can taste of course taste it's
not not a big problem we came over here
so ago d3 is karate one young mmm okay
so let's grab you five gentle King I'd
hope that the active King position is so
is a nice asset material is live for now
but my King has some right in the action
here middle of the board
hmm yes should be should be great for
black I play with an extra king check
okay he will get this pawn of course but
if I go rook c5 f5 I can I can cover it
yeah this is good I can just on f5 my
rook Kavis b5 + f7 and in the meantime
my King is just getting the hawk inside
the rukns he follows also at the moment
blocking the King yep yep if he takes I
take with the form I can I wouldn't just
sell Hawking side no nothing he can do
about that
hmm okay and when it's lost anyway but
still um this is really easy
white resigns yeah and basically we
blended the c-4 pond but I some some
weird stuff after them if that still
happened I came yeah this is probably
probably okay up to that point but yeah
around here they got a shot should look
for improvements came and here maybe I
know Bishop c5 or something I really am
I really forgot about books he won and
he can play whoopsy one now this would
have been would have been much more
testing here proxy one I need to move
the Queen of course then I just I just
gave away my my good position here this
is completely unclear but he didn't he
didn't go for that deeply aged for now I
strive have a good end game because of
my activity this is yeah the computer
gives like a flat-out win here he had
the king it's just just basically an
additional piece in the game well
White's King is on b1 and after that it
wasn't wasn't even too difficult okay
thanks for watching